[Music]  pirates had infected the seas for  generations  so I filed preliminary the mall  [Music]  and then there was this boy  just borrow  follow him he took everything from me  reach the dead I've taken command of the  sea girl I've heard stories  the mighty Spanish captain whose son had  been killed thousands of men no no no  men no pirates pirates I once knew a  Spaniard learn something in Spanish  he's coming future  personal [ __ ] the crew  your pants Jackie I'm so sorry were you  still talking there's nowhere to hide  find spy refer me  this woman thought we ought to be our  lives  just chittering where your left hand as  I said we're more than that  monkey  looking for trouble horrible anally  paying for what you did  remember Matt Chopin looking for jacket  I'm going to swim for it Karina stop  that oh no no no that's okay this has  gone far enough  no it has not I saw her ankles you just  seen a lot more if you kept the cake  holeshot